testing has already become part of our
lives now if you get coveted you'll be
offered this
run by the uk health security agency
it's a chance to test your antibodies
when you first get the virus and then 28
days later the government is wrestling
with the decisions this autumn around
booster vaccination who to boost
um
knowing individuals
who don't mount an effective or a very
high antibody response
may be clinically useful because they
could be singled out for vaccination so
a much more targeted vaccine program
could be possible than what we're doing
at the moment which is just saying
everybody get that gets vaccinated
health secretary sajid javid said he was
proud to see all parts of the uk uniting
around this new initiative and working
together to arm ourselves with even more
valuable insights into how covert 19
vaccines are protecting people up and
down the uk
latest figures have suggested that over
90 percent of adults in england have got
antibodies tear the weight strip off and
then just feed it together and that's
numbers still show over 32 000 cases in
the uk
events like the mela festival in luton
are feeling the impact
2019 was the last time it was held it's
again been cancelled
this weekend wardown park should have
been packed with thousands of people but
because the rates of covid here in luton
are slightly higher than other parts of
the east of england the organisers
decided only last weekend that they had
to cancel just another sign of how the
virus is still having an impact on the
way that we live
in the park we met tina and tracy and
their mum gene who has dementia and
lives in a care home
they're still restricted on how they can
see her and hope antibody tests would
change that it can't be that complicated
because the other stuff the other tests
aren't complicated and it just makes you
know where you are make you feel safer
when you're out and about if you know
that you've got good cover in your
antibodies so yeah hopefully it will get
them out of the home yes
8 000 tests a day are going to be
available for people who test positive
all of it vital information for the
government as we brace for potential new
variants and another phase of
vaccinations
rhiannon mills sky news in luton